[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALAN MOSS: Welcome
to Talks at Google.
I'm Alan Moss.
I'm Vice President of
Sales and Operations here,
and it is my distinct
pleasure to welcome Leslie
Berlin to Talks at Google.
LESLIE BERLIN: Thank you.
ALAN MOSS: Leslie is the author
of the recently published book
"Troublemakers--
Silicon Valley's Coming of Age."
Her first book was "The
Man Behind the Microchip--
Robert Noyce and the
Invention of Silicon Valley."
She is Project Historian for
the Silicon Valley Archives
at Stanford University.
And she's been a columnist
for the New York Times
and commented on technology
in Silicon Valley
for the Wall Street Journal,
NPR, BBC, the Atlantic, PBS,
Wired--
you get it.
So really thrilled to
have Leslie today and host
a conversation on her new book.
So what we'll do is I'll have
an opportunity to talk a bit
and have this
conversation with Leslie,
and then we'll open it
up to your questions.
Googlers are
usually not bashful.
And we have a mic here,
and special inducement--
particularly good
questions will also
come with a book,
a copy of your own.
With that, welcome, Leslie.
Great to have you here.
LESLIE BERLIN: Thank you.
ALAN MOSS: So where to start?
In "Troublemakers,"
you chronicle
seven individuals who were
in the technology space
the very early days,
so 1969 to about 1984,
and their contributions to not
only founding new industries
in video gaming, personal
computing, biotechnology,
and many more.
How did you choose to
focus on these individuals?
LESLIE BERLIN: Well, the
first thing I did was I
put together a timeline
of Silicon Valley
history, just with a dot for
each kind of significant event.
And in this period between 1969
and 1976, the density of dots
was unmatched
anywhere, because you
had the founding of Apple,
Genentech, Atari, Kleiner
Perkins, Sequoia Capital.
You had the first
ARPANET transmission
that turns into the internet.
You had the birth of the
independent software business.
You had the invention of the
microchip, the microprocessor.
And it was like watching
the big bang, basically.
Just [EXPLOSION SOUND].
Because before this
time, Silicon Valley
was like this
regional backwater,
wasn't even called
Silicon Valley.
It sort of existed around
one industry, which
was microchips, semiconductors.
And it was gearheads
selling to gearheads.
And at the end of--
really if you just
look at the first
seven years, you
have personal computing
and video games.
So you have the first really
high-tech consumer electronics
making it out into the world,
microprocessor-based consumer
electronics.
You have the biotech
industry being born
and modern venture capital.
It was crazy to see
what had happened.
And then I was
trying to figure out,
how on Earth do you tell a
story that is this complicated?
And I decided that
the answer had
to be that you had
to find good people
to tell this story through.
Because I don't
know how many of you
have ever sat through
reading about the invention
of a particular
piece of technology.
And that can be kind
of dry, whereas I
think that the stories of how
people did it, and sometimes
how they failed to do
it, are very interesting.
So my criteria were three.
I wanted to find people
who were largely unknown--
that was really important to me.
So this is why when
I write about Apple,
for example, I don't
write about Jobs,
and I don't write about Wozniak.
I mean, they're both peripheral
characters next to the person
who's my main focus,
who is Mike Markkula.
And most people don't
know about Mike,
but Mike owned a third of
Apple along with Jobs and Woz
when they started the company.
And he was the guy who came to
the famous garage in Cupertino
and saw these two guys who--
I mean, Jobs was 21.
Woz was a few years older.
Jobs would have loved to figure
out how to start a company,
but he had 17 months of business
experience in his entire life,
and that was as
a tech for Atari.
Woz would have been happy
to stay at HP forever
and ever as an engineer.
As a matter of fact, he
tried to sell the Apple I--
he tried to give the Apple I
to HP, and they didn't want it.
So I knew that there
were tons and tons
of these little companies,
these little personal computer
wannabe companies in what we now
call Silicon Valley, in places
like Albuquerque.
So what was it that was
special about this company?
Because they all had a
Jobs-ian type, not as
brilliant as Steve Jobs.
They all had a Wozniak-ian
type, not as brilliant as Woz,
perhaps.
But none of them
had a Mike Markkula.
And Mike had retired from Intel.
He'd gotten there
before the IPO.
He had watched this
little bitty company that
was in another company's castoff
space grow into what it became.
And he knew how to
turn this idea he saw,
which was the Apple II,
into what Apple became,
which was the youngest
company ever to make it
into the Fortune 500.
So I wanted to tell the
stories of those people whose
roles were so important
but nobody knew them.
And what inspired it,
actually, was I was at a party,
and at this party was
the COO of a company that
has a superstar CEO.
And this COO started
singing a little song,
and the song's only words
were, "I did all the work,
he got all the credit."
[LAUGHTER]
And I thought, you know, for
all the people in the spotlight,
even the people who deserve
to be in the spotlight,
there are so many people who
are just outside the spotlight,
without whom that person in the
spotlight would never be there.
And so I wanted to tell
those people's stories.
ALAN MOSS: That's great.
LESLIE BERLIN: Yeah, so that
was criteria one, right?
They had to be unknown.
Criteria two, they
had to be important.
There are plenty of unknowns
who don't do anything important.
And then the third
criteria was they
had to be really, really
interesting people,
for just what I was
talking about earlier.
This is a book for
a general audience.
It's a bunch of
stories in addition
to having these sort
of broader themes,
and it's underpinned by 100
pages of notes at the back.
It's a very deeply researched
I-have-a-PhD-in-history kind
of book.
But it's all buried
super-duper deep so
that the stories can come up.
And if that's what
you're trying to do,
you have to have really
interesting people
to talk about.
So that's how I chose the time.
That how I chose the people.
ALAN MOSS: Great.
Thank you.
I won't ask you who that COO is.
I'm guessing that
won't be revealed.
LESLIE BERLIN: And
I would not tell.
ALAN MOSS: So since you
introduced Mike Markkula
so well, let's maybe briefly
introduce the other characters.
Maybe I can read them
out, and you could sort of
give us a couple-liner
on why Bob
Taylor at first the Pentagon
and then Xerox PARC.
LESLIE BERLIN: Yeah, so
Bob Taylor is probably
the person in the book
who has the widest
gap between how
important what he did was
and how unknown he is.
Bob Taylor is the
guy who convinced
the Department of Defense
to start what today we
call the internet,
to start the ARPANET.
Then he, after that,
went to Xerox PARC,
where he ran that lab that came
up with all of the components--
with their sister lab;
the System Science
Lab was the sister lab--
that came up with
all the components
of the modern personal computer,
kind of put them together.
That's the place
that had first had
the overlapping
windows, and WYSIWYG,
and the mouse first in place.
By 1977 this lab had the ability
to have someone in Miami--
I saw a demo of this, it
knocked my socks off--
controlling the cursor on the
screen of someone in Palo Alto,
in 1977.
So Taylor ran that lab.
That's the lab that Steve
Jobs famously visited in 1979
and saw all this in
action and said, hm,
I want that for Apple.
And it moved into the Lisa
and then later into the Mac.
And Taylor ran this lab with--
he had a master's
degree in psychology
and was running this lab that
was so full of brilliant PhD
computer scientists that
the president of MIT
worried aloud that the
future of computer science
education in the United
States was questionable,
because everyone great was
working for Bob Taylor.
That includes Eric Schmidt
of Google worked for Taylor.
The co-founders of Adobe,
Geschke and Warnock,
worked for Taylor.
Charles Simonyi, who
went on to do the Office
Suite at Microsoft,
worked for Taylor.
Larry Tesler, who is key at Ap--
I mean, it can
just go on and on.
Alan Kay was brought to
Xerox PARC by Bob Taylor.
So this incredibly important
guy, no one knows what he did.
Oh, and then he went on DEC,
where they had Altavista.
One of his researchers was
the key guy behind Altavista,
many years before Google was
a glimmer in anyone's eye.
So--
ALAN MOSS: Enough said.
LESLIE BERLIN: --super
important, yeah.
ALAN MOSS: How about
Al Alcorn of Atari?
LESLIE BERLIN: Al Alcorn.
Al Alcorn was the
designer of Pong,
the first huge video
game for Atari,
and a really interesting guy.
Because he is an
engineer's engineer.
And I really wanted
to be sure to capture
the stories of people
who were heads down,
doing the engineering.
But again, fascinating guy--
had a picture of Lyndon Johnson
on his wall in the late '60s
and used him for
target practice.
[LAUGHTER]
Very interesting guy.
ALAN MOSS: That's great.
Fawn Alvarez and ROLM.
LESLIE BERLIN: Fawn Alvarez is
someone when the book opens,
she's 12 years old, and
she is picking fruit
in the orchards that used to
be all over Silicon Valley.
It was called the Valley
of the Heart's Delight.
And she is doing this in the
bucolic haven of Cupertino,
California.
And she goes on--
she doesn't go to college,
but she gets a job
on the manufacturing
line at ROLM.
Something that most people
don't know about Silicon Valley
is that this used to be
a manufacturing economy.
There were factories here.
They were called fabs,
but they were here.
And they anchored the economy.
And there were plenty of
very, very good middle class
jobs for people who
didn't have an education
beyond a high school degree.
And I wanted her story
to be there because A,
she illuminates that
sort of transition
from the orchards
to manufacturing,
and then she keeps going
and ends up as, essentially,
the chief of staff
to the president
of IBM ROLM as ROLM
itself is moving
all of its manufacturing
out of the area.
And she moves much more
into the Silicon Valley jobs
that we think of today.
ALAN MOSS: Yeah, great.
These next two are
sort of a paired set,
with Niels Reimers of Stanford's
Office of Technology Licensing
and Bob Swanson of Genentech.
LESLIE BERLIN: Right.
So this is the story of
the biotech industry.
I mean, it took me six
years to write this book,
and part of the reason it
did was that it's basically
six books in one book.
So Niels Reimers is the guy
who started Stanford's Office
of Technology Licensing.
When he got to
Stanford in 1970, he
saw that Stanford's entire
income from the inventions
of all of its faculty,
staff, and students
for the previous 13 years
had been $3,000 combined,
about $260 a year.
He decided that
didn't make any sense.
He decided to try
to start something,
and he was not a
high-powered, high-level guy.
He was sort of a mid-level
staffer, and not an attorney,
either.
And he started the office that,
to date, has brought $2 billion
into Stanford.
And that office is the
reason that Stanford
had a stake in Google's
search algorithm
and had a nice chunk
of equity in Google.
Similar for VMware-- that's
another big one out of Stanford
Office of Technology Licensing.
And this talks about their
first really big hit, which was
the patent for recombinant DNA.
The whole notion of patenting
this process was a radical one.
He faced a lot of challenges.
And one of the people he worked
closely with from early on
was Bob Swanson, who was
the co-founder of Genentech
and someone who he'd been
an associate partner.
He was like a rocket ship,
superstar guy, takes a chance,
and becomes an
associate partner, one
of the first ones--
maybe the first one?
I'm not sure-- at Kleiner
Perkins Caulfield and Byers.
Gets fired, and I mean, was
really rocked back on his heels
and decides that
he really believes
in this thing he's read about,
which is recombinant DNA.
He's read about it in
"Science" magazine.
Can't find anyone to help
him start this company,
ends up going on welfare while
he tries to figure it out--
it's very much sort of a
JK Rowling type story--
and ends up launching Genentech.
ALAN MOSS: Unbelievable.
Great story.
LESLIE BERLIN: Yeah,
it's a great story.
ALAN MOSS: And last but not
least, Sandy Kurtzig, Founder
and CEO of ASK Computer.
LESLIE BERLIN: Right, so Sandy
Kurtzig is the first woman
to take a tech company public.
She started a software
company called ASK in 1972.
And I wanted to write about
Sandy primarily because I
wanted to write about software.
This is the first time,
not just her company,
but this is the time when,
in the wake of an IBM consent
decree, software and hardware
are unbundled from each other.
And so you get these independent
little bitty software companies
coming up.
This was Silicon Valley at
a time when, I just said,
they were building things.
It was a hardware place.
And even Larry Ellison,
who started Oracle
at around this exact
same time, talked
about how he couldn't get
anyone to pay attention
to his entreaties
to give him money
to start a software company.
He said that the
venture capitalists just
laughed him out of the office.
And so Sandy was
interesting to me
because she's an outsider
because she's doing software,
and she's an outsider
because she's a woman.
So people literally think when
she says she's selling software
that she's selling lingerie.
And so her story--
she's someone who comes up kind
of outside these famed networks
that other people
like Mike Markkula
was able to bring Apple into.
If you look at Apple's
S1 at their IPO,
almost every single
senior exec plus,
their funders all had
ties through Markkula
to the semiconductor industry.
Not the case for Sandy Kurtzig.
She bootstrapped it
from her kitchen table.
And HP gave them time on their
computers late, late at night.
That was sort of as
close as she came
to tapping into this
network and again, was
a story I wanted to pull out.
Because HP now has
really diminished
in people's understanding
of its importance,
but they brought up so many--
dozens of these little software
companies couldn't
afford computers.
They were hundreds of
thousands of dollars.
How could you possibly
afford one of those?
But you could go in
after hours at HP.
Literally you could
bring a sleeping bag
and sleep on a
floor in the closet
and use their computers
to try to debug your code.
So it was an
exciting story, too.
ALAN MOSS: Yeah, that's great.
And arguably one of the earliest
independent software vendors,
as they used to be
known, or ISVs out there.
LESLIE BERLIN: Yeah, exactly.
In the applications
business-- it's
funny we've gone back to that.
That's how they talked
about themselves then.
ALAN MOSS: Indeed.
So with your
background in history,
you note there's
five major industries
in seven years between 1969
and 1976 that are born.
They are the personal
computing, video games, biotech,
modern venture capital,
and advanced semiconductor
industries.
As you look back in
other times in history,
has there ever been
another time like this,
in terms of the kind
of inventiveness?
How does it compare?
LESLIE BERLIN: You
know, I didn't come up
with anything that was
really comparable in terms
of the breadth and impact.
I mean, that is just--
when you look at
where we are today,
you can trace so much of it
back to this tiny little place
in this little period of time.
And I think that, to me, it was
unrivaled and actually points
to one of the
things that I always
think is so interesting
about Silicon Valley, which
is that this has been
the birthplace of so
many different things.
In this case, I'm talking
about one generation.
But people always
want to understand.
People come to
Stanford all the time.
Why did Silicon Valley
get started here?
But to me a much more
interesting question is, why
is Silicon Valley still going?
I mean, Hewlett-Packard
started in 1939.
Why is it still going?
And why have there been so
many different generations
of technology that have
come out of this place?
Because, I mean, you start with
HP and with instrumentation,
and then you're into
the chips, and then
you're into the sort of
stuff I'm talking about,
consumer electronics
and biotech.
And then you're into
networking, and then--
I mean, you can just kind
of keep going forward.
And then we're in cloud,
and mobile, and search.
Cars are here.
And so how did all that happen?
And I think that I always
point to two things, actually.
One is the role of
people doing what
Mike Markkula did in this book.
When Jobs spoke at
Stanford in 2005,
he talked about when
he was fired from Apple
and how the first thing he
did was pick up the phone
and call Bob Noyce, who is
the subject of my first book
and a co-founder of
Intel, and David Packard.
And Jobs said, I apologized
for dropping the baton.
And he had this sense of
sort of this relay race
across time, generation
to generation,
handing off the baton.
And I think that's been such
an important part of Silicon
Valley history.
And I think that,
in some sense, part
of what I hope
this book can serve
as is a baton pass, sort
of like, well, here's
how this generation did it.
And then the second thing
that I always point to
is how important
immigrants have been
to the rise of Silicon Valley.
Basically in the time that I'm
writing about, we're still--
people are coming here from
other parts of the world,
I mean, from other parts
of the United States
at an insane rate.
It was as if a new
person moved into Silicon
Valley every half hour
for 20 years straight,
and no one moved out.
ALAN MOSS: Wow.
LESLIE BERLIN: I mean, that's
the pace at which people
were coming into
the Valley, mostly
from other parts of the country.
Now they come from
all over the world,
but the effect has been
exactly the same, which
is this constant refresh
into the system of new ideas,
the best and brightest, and very
often the biggest risk takers.
Because what it takes to pick
up and leave your country, often
your language, your
family, your home
to try to do something really
different is so important.
And at this point we've
got 2/3 of the people
working in science and
tech in Silicon Valley
are born outside of
the United States.
So that's been another sort of
secret to the Valley's success.
And I think that while I
can't see a comparable time
period for this book, I
feel like, in some ways,
it was almost like
the firing gun
for everything that
has come since.
ALAN MOSS: The starting block.
Yeah, that's great.
Maybe that's a good place to
ask you to read an excerpt
and set the scene.
A bunch of us live in
Silicon Valley here,
and you mentioned the
orchards and manufacturing.
I'd love to ask you to read
a passage from the book that
maybe gives us a
sense of what it was
like at the end of
the '60s, early '70s
and what that sort
of formative period
was like, if you don't mind.
LESLIE BERLIN: Great.
We talked about this in
advance, so I have it marked.
So the way the book is
organized, I should explain,
is it has what I think
of as core samples.
It's different time periods.
So I've got all
these seven people.
One way you could have done this
book is talk about person A--
here's what they
were doing 1969.
We're going to follow
them all the way through.
Now we're going to move our
person B all the way through.
That, to me, was going to lose
the magic of the story, which
is that these people's
lives, they just
keep kind of overlapping.
I mean, Don Valentine shows
up again and again and again.
And they had Larry Sonsini--
he's here and he's
here and he's here.
Regis McKenna-- just
the same people.
And so I wanted to make sure--
in order, venture
capitalist, attorney, PR guy.
The best in the
business, all of them.
I wanted to find a way
to overlap those stories.
So I tell where everyone
is in each time period.
And I start those time periods
with a sort of, you are here.
This is what Silicon Valley
was like at this time.
So this is for the sort of
1972 to '75 time period.
I'll just read you it.
"In 1971, a hard
drinking reporter
named Don Hoefler published
a three-part history
of the men, money,
and litigation
behind the
semiconductor business.
He titled the series, which
appeared in an industry
newsletter called Electronic
News, 'Silicon Valley, USA.'
It was the first formal
use of a name that had,
for years, been bandied
about inside the Valley.
"No one beyond the
readers of Electronic News
took notice of
the new technology
region that had been born on
the San Francisco Peninsula.
Individual companies had begun
to attract outside interest.
So Intel had its IPO in
that same year, 1971.
But it would be
three years before
any major national publication
wrote about the Peninsula
as a distinct
technology-based region.
Years would pass
before the name Silicon
Valley gained widespread use."
And it's actually really
funny all the other names
that people came up
with-- it was Silicon
Gulch, Semiconductor Country.
Semiconductor Country
is pretty good.
"In the early 1970s, Silicon
Valley startup companies
were largely deemed irrelevant
to the real business
of the United States, which
was concentrated in East Coast
financial centers in cities
such as Detroit, and Pittsburgh,
and Chicago that had
manufacturing at their core."
The nation's new mini
computer companies--
these were kind of the hot
thing that everyone knew about--
were all clustered
around MIT and Harvard
along Boston's Route 128.
OK, so here's what was going on.
Stanford's reputation
was on the rise,
which we know because
it was beginning to be
called the Harvard of the West.
"But still, the university
attracted mostly students
from California.
San Francisco was best
known for its hippies.
Palo Alto was fighting
its reputation as quote
'the Peninsula's largest
sex shop center,' thanks
to an eight-block stretch
of El Camino Real near
the city's southern border
that was home to multiple adult
bookstores, an
X-rated movie theater,
and massage parlors with names
such as The Streaker and The
Foxy Lady."
This is down the street from
my first house, actually.
"None of this pointed
to a promising future
as an economic powerhouse.
The rest of the business
world might not have noticed,
but inside Silicon Valley,
things were brewing in 1972.
The previous year, Intel had
invented the microprocessor,
the chip that would soon
nestle at the heart of consumer
electronics such as the personal
computer and video games.
"Meanwhile, Hewlett-Packard
became the first Silicon Valley
company to discover that an
advanced electronic device
could have broad
consumer appeal.
In 1972, the company introduced
the HP-35, the world's
first handheld calculator
that could do more than add,
subtract, multiply, and divide.
HP sold more than 100,000 in
the first year, despite a $400
price tag."
Which is a very
significant price tag.
This was my favorite part.
"A cheeky chapter called
Shirt Pocket Power
in the owner's manual noted,
'We thought you'd like to have
something only fictional heroes
like James Bond, Walter Mitty,
or Dick Tracy are supposed
to own.'" For a pocket
calculator--
I just love that.
"For the most part,
these developments
within Silicon Valley happened
independently of one another.
But like different streams
that feed a swift-moving river,
the work would soon begin
to blend and swirl together.
The resulting network of
personal and institutional
connections would
form the foundation
of today's Silicon Valley
and the high technology
revolution."
ALAN MOSS: Fabulous.
LESLIE BERLIN: So that's
sort of where we were.
And look where we are now.
ALAN MOSS: Just a
little bit different,
for those of you that
live in the area,
a little different picture
of the local environment
back in the early '70s.
LESLIE BERLIN: Yeah,
and especially people
looking at the Valley
from the East Coast--
I mean, it's amazing.
In the book you mainly see this
because Xerox is headquartered
on the East Coast.
And so they're looking at these
crazies in Palo Alto who--
I mean, this is a company who
almost all of their profits
came from the paper that they
sold with the Xerox machines.
And here they've got
this research lab that's
gone completely rogue and
is trying to figure out,
how do we start doing all
of the important stuff
before it ever even
hits the paper?
And their descriptions of
Xerox PARC and this area
are hilarious.
I mean, they're just sort of
like, everyone eats tofu there.
People jog.
I mean, it's just amazing to
see how suspicious people were.
They were watching
the television.
They were seeing
what was going on
in San Francisco and these
protests in Berkeley,
because the Vietnam War
is just at its height.
Had a huge implication
for what happened here,
because so many people
who would have gone--
if you were a graphics
expert at this time,
what were you going to do?
You were going to go work for
the Department of Defense,
almost certainly, or
maybe a subcontractor.
But all of the sudden you
have these people coming out
of school, and they don't want
anything to do with the DoD.
They don't want anything to do
with the war that's happening.
And that is to
the gain of places
like Xerox PARC, and Atari,
and eventually Apple.
Silicon Valley's history,
really too often for my money,
is told in total
isolation from what's
going on in the
rest of the country,
much less the rest of the world.
And so this is a great
example of why it mattered.
Who would have
thought that would
have been a consequence of the
Vietnam War, but it really was.
ALAN MOSS: Yeah, and all the
interleaving effects that lead
to these different companies,
it's amazing to think about.
Since you mentioned
Xerox PARC, I've
always been fascinated
with their history.
So many core
technological inventions
came from there and from the
assemblage of amazing talent
that Taylor brought together.
Yet they failed to
commercialize those inventions.
And so I'm curious, what's
your perspective on why
did Xerox fail?
Was it some of this skepticism
towards Silicon Valley
and the West Coast?
And also, how did Bob
Taylor think about that?
Was he troubled by the
fact that Xerox never
reaped the benefits
of the inventions that
came from his operation?
LESLIE BERLIN: Yeah,
so this is called--
"Fumbling the Future"
is the term everyone
uses for a very nasty
book about Xerox.
Xerox fumbled the future,
because the argument goes Apple
could have been Xerox's.
Adobe could have been Xerox's.
Microsoft, certainly
everything that
followed in the wake
of Windows, could have
could have belonged to Xerox.
So that's the argument.
And Alan's question is
how did how did Xerox
fumble the future?
So Xerox would very
quickly point out,
we did not fumble the future.
The printer, the laser
printer is another thing
that was invented at
Xerox PARC, again,
with basically a refugee from
a different part of Xerox
who had this idea to do this.
And they didn't want to do it.
And Taylor was like, come to us.
We will help you do this.
So Xerox commercialized
the laser printer
and made back way more
money than they ever
spent on Xerox PARC.
So they would completely say
that is an irrelevant question.
And it makes perfect sense that
a company whose entire business
model ran on paper would
actually commercialize the one
thing that came out of
this place that used up
paper, which was a printer.
So they would object
to that, for sure--
and with some legitimacy.
I think that no one in
the world could hold on
to the talent and ideas that
were coming out of that place.
Silicon Valley has these places.
So the first one was
Fairchild Semiconductor,
which was just this incredible
compression of brilliance.
So you look at the eight
founders of Fairchild,
and among them are Bob Noyce,
who co-invented the microchip,
and his partner Gordon
Moore, who goes on
to start Intel with him,
and Eugene Kleiner, who
starts Kleiner Perkins, and Jean
Hoerni, who invents the planar
process, which is
underpinning, still,
chip manufacturing today.
And you just keep going.
I mean, the people who
worked at Fairchild
include Don Valentine,
Charlie Sporck.
The companies that came out of
it are Intel, AMD, National.
I mean, you can just keep going.
Well, that company just
went [EXPLOSION SOUND]..
And it was like a seed
pod scattering its seeds
all over the area that then
became the chip industry.
Xerox PARC was another
one of those places.
In more recent memory,
PayPal is another one
of those places that just sort
of does great things when it's
together, and then the
founders and the key employees
kind of go on to populate
what happens next.
And this just happens.
So Taylor could not
have given a darn
about whether his stuff
got commercialized.
He really felt, he believed
that the main interesting thing
in this world was research.
If you want to waste your time
on marketing, and lawyers,
and money, and
finances, fine with him.
But he didn't care.
I mean, I asked him once
about the money that he made,
because I just told
you all the people who
came from his company.
And they all loved him.
He undoubtedly had
the ability to invest
in all of the companies I just
laid out, on the ground floor.
And he had so little
interest in money
that he started talking
about his 401(k) plan.
He didn't get what
I was talking about.
That just isn't what
kind of floated his boat.
But when his people
started leaving--
because engineers and
these computer scientists,
they don't want
to build something
that gets buried and
no one ever uses it,
when they know it's incredible.
They want it-- and when
his people started leaving,
then he lost it.
He was furious.
He was so angry.
ALAN MOSS: That's
so [INAUDIBLE]..
Yeah, and I think really one
of the world's great research
labs.
And some things
never change, right?
Engineers want their products
used by not only millions
these days, but billions are
possible with the internet.
LESLIE BERLIN: And a
number of the sort of
graybeards even
now at Google who
are just sort of doing the
research, those are Taylor.
They worked for Bob Taylor.
Bob hosted a tomato fest
in his yard every year.
And it was like here come
the Turing Award winners,
and here comes a major mind
behind Google Translate.
Here they're all just kind of
descending into his backyard.
It was incredible.
It was like a magnet.
ALAN MOSS: Yeah, talk
about an eye for talent.
LESLIE BERLIN: Yeah.
ALAN MOSS: That's great.
So I want to ask you about the
two women that you profile.
And obviously a lot
of talk these days
about women in Silicon
Valley, under-representation.
I'd love to ask you
what's the same,
and what has changed
from earlier times
about being a woman
in tech and in Silicon
Valley from your perspective.
LESLIE BERLIN: Yeah.
I appreciate that
question being asked
in that same versus different,
as opposed to better versus
worse.
Because that's a really
tough question to answer.
So I would say it has never
been easy for women in tech
in Silicon Valley, but
for different reasons
now than then.
So the things that the women
in my book had to put up with--
and I interviewed a number
of women, because the women
were there.
I mean, they were
designing the video games,
they were programming
the computers,
they were inventing
the icons on the Mac.
But they were not brought
to the surface at all
in a lot of these stories.
So I talked to a lot
more women than who
are the subject of the book.
And the things that they faced--
it would curl your hair.
I mean, I can't even--
it's one of those things where I
can't speak about this in front
of a family-friendly audience.
And I didn't actually put
a lot of it in the book.
But there are things
that I put in the book,
like the literally
pornographic short story
that Atari published, written
by one of its employees,
in the company newsletter.
And just hot tub parties--
board meetings were
held in hot tubs.
I mean, it's behavior
that in some ways
looks super familiar
to the worst
stories we're hearing now.
But what was really hard for
me to get my mind around--
really hard--
is that this was
happening at a time
when the surrounding culture was
so different in a lot of ways
from how it is now.
So in the mid '70s--
I think it was 1974 or
1975 before a woman,
a married woman, could just get
a credit card in her own name
without her
husband's permission.
And it was 1980 before the EEOC
recognized sexual harassment
in the workplace.
And so the overriding
culture was such
that when IBM showed women
using computers, which they
did in sort of their
flagship offices in New York,
the women doing the work
because it was their job
were told that they were
being put in the window
because then it
would be clear to men
that this was easy to do.
And the women I talked
to, I would say,
that was such explicit
sexual harassment!
I can't believe the things
that these people said and did.
And they'd say, oh, no,
that was just so-and-so.
He's a jerk.
Or, no, you know,
everyone was doing that.
And so was it was
it harder for them?
I don't know, because the
expectations were so different.
And these surroundings
were so different.
It really was a tough-- you
can hear from the way I'm
talking about it now.
It's still kind of hard for
me to get my mind around.
Sandy Kurtzig said
that-- and Sandy Kurtzig,
who was mistaken for a booth
babe because she was very
beautiful, and told to go get
coffee for people when she was
the CEO that they were
trying to sell to--
she said that the fact
that she was the boss
made all the difference
in the world.
She was calling the shots.
And so I think that sort
of speaks to something
that a lot of people are
talking about now, as being one
of the possible among the
constellation of many solutions
we have to come up with.
ALAN MOSS: It's more
women in leadership.
LESLIE BERLIN: Yeah,
that's exactly right.
And I think, kind of getting
back to that baton pass
image of Steve Jobs,
the question of, OK,
how do we make sure there are
a whole lot of batons going
all at once and that
they're being handed off,
not just to the usual suspects
and not just to the person who
you wrote for the "Stanford
Review" with, but other people.
How is that all
going to work out?
And it's kind of incumbent
on us to figure that out.
ALAN MOSS: Yeah.
Thank you.
Great perspective.
So the title's "Troublemakers."
Why that title?
What's the common
attribute, perhaps,
that all of these
seven people have
in terms of the trouble
that they're creating
at this formative time?
LESLIE BERLIN: Yeah.
Titles are incredibly hard to
come up with, I have to say.
We had this one, then we
went to some other ones
that never quite sat right,
came back to this one.
The source of it
actually is another,
I guess, Steve Jobs story.
When he comes back
to Apple in 1996,
and then they bring out
the ad the next year that--
it's "Here's to the crazy
ones, the troublemakers,
the square pegs in round
holes," or however it goes.
It's in the front of the book.
And that really captured,
to me, the essence of what
these people were doing.
One title we considered
was "Disruptors," which I'm
really glad we didn't go with.
But there was the
notion at this time that
to do what you needed to
do, you couldn't do it
inside the existing boundaries
that kind of constrained you.
But there wasn't
the notion of, I'm
just going to blow
this up for no reason.
It was much more, I want
to accomplish this thing,
and here's how I have to do it.
So Sandy Kurtzig, she couldn't
get money from anyone--
she had to get it from her dad.
It wasn't some sort of
a I'm going to stick it
to the banks kind of idea.
Or the whole notion
of dressing casually--
why is it that none of us
is in a suit right now?
Well, that wasn't some sort
of stick it to the man,
I don't want to be constrained
by the ideals of a broader
society.
It was that all of
these people were--
most of them are coming
straight out of college.
A lot of them were starting
companies straight out
of college, and they
just started out in jeans
and kept going.
Or, they were these
computer scientists
who couldn't get time on
computers except late at night.
And so that's a big part
of where the casual work
hours came from, too, was
that it just sort of naturally
flowed out of the
academic world that
surrounded people and the kind
of loosey-goosey counterculture
feature.
And in terms of what these
people had in common,
I would say they had an
unusual set of characteristics
in common.
One was they were
simultaneously--
they were audacious and
they were persistent.
And sometimes those
two don't go together.
You'll have the people who have
sort of the big out-there idea.
And Bob Noyce was one of these
people-- big out-there idea,
and then he wants
to go out and find
the next big out-there idea.
And Gordon Moore is
behind him like, OK, well,
that's a good one.
That's a bad idea.
These people tended,
almost to a person,
to be able to have the big
idea and to follow through
on the big idea,
or to find people
who could follow through.
So audacity and persistence.
And I think the
third feature that I
would point to is an
appreciation of the team.
None of these people set out
to be, or saw themselves as,
an independent rock star, kind
of doing this for the adoring
acolytes who are
their employees.
I mean, it was very much of a
sense that we're all in this
together.
And I think those
three cover a lot,
because their ancillary
characteristics
that kind of fall out of
them are pretty significant.
ALAN MOSS: Yeah.
So you talked about passing the
baton and other industries sort
of benefiting from each other.
And the semiconductor industry,
sort of in the backdrop,
plays a very big part in
a lot of these companies.
A lot of the talent--
Mike Markkula, one example,
then going to Apple,
but other examples like that.
What was it about the early
experience in the semiconductor
industry that set
these individuals up
to become such great
technologists and executives
in these other industries?
LESLIE BERLIN: Yeah, so I
think that what the chip
industry gave people was a
sort of understanding of,
at that time, how this worked
for a very complicated idea,
to become a business.
I think also the
infrastructure that
was built up to support chip
entrepreneurs turned out
to be the exact
same infrastructure
that these consumer electronics
companies plugged into,
that then biotech plugged
into, that still--
I mean, think of how important
Sequoia is to this day.
People are still plugging
into these same networks
that were set up.
I think that something that the
semiconductor industry couldn't
help with was figuring out
how to sell to consumers.
So as you know, Apple
almost died in the period
that Jobs was gone.
And I think that they didn't
have anyone there who really
knew how to sell to consumers.
And one of the things that's
really interesting to me
is they bring in John
Sculley, and everyone laughs.
Oh my god, this PepsiCo guy.
What's he doing?
But what they were trying
to do is figure out,
how the heck do you
sell to a consumer?
So the chip industry was
vitally important on one level,
and on some level
this generation
had to get beyond the
one that came before.
And that's just
the way it works.
The example I always use is
of a grain of sand in a pearl
and how you can have
those sort of chips
at the center, this
little grain there,
but then you build these
layers around it and around it.
Again, those generations
that I'm talking about.
So now we're out here,
and it's very easy to,
out where we are in this part,
this is a very big pearl.
And it's hard to imagine
that yeah, back down
at the core we're still
dealing with those chips.
Because so much has
been added to it.
So you do, you lean on it, but
you've got to move beyond it.
ALAN MOSS: Yeah, that's great.
So I'd love to ask
you-- there's so
many different great
personalities profiled
in the book.
If you had the opportunity
to work with one of them
in their prime, who
would it be and why?
LESLIE BERLIN: OK.
If I had the opportunity to work
with, as a peer, one of them,
it would be Fawn
Alvarez, because she
is a firecracker and hilarious.
And I really, really like her.
I would have loved to
work for Bob Taylor--
if he liked me.
[LAUGHS] I would not have
wanted him to work for me.
He was a very difficult
man to have work for you.
But he created an environment.
Everyone who worked
for him who loved
him talks about this
sort of protected world
that he created for innovation,
and creativity, and execution
that I think just
would have been
magnificent to be a part of.
ALAN MOSS: Sounds like
if he didn't like you
it wasn't quite as pleasant.
LESLIE BERLIN: You were gone.
ALAN MOSS: You were gone.
Interesting.
And so we'll open up for
questions in just a minute.
My last question will
be sort of turning
to some of the high-tech
companies today.
Lots of the world's
most valuable companies
these days are in high tech.
And so I'm curious what
companies like Google, Amazon,
Facebook, name your
favorites, have learned
from these predecessors.
What's the foundation
that they're standing on
that you think
should be recognized
or maybe hasn't been
recognized as much
and should be as we all grow up?
LESLIE BERLIN: Well,
I mean, something
that I think has been really
interesting that seems to still
be embedded in the DNA in
a lot of these companies
is the founder continuing
on, whether he or she,
or it's usually they--
the lone founder
concept is just a myth.
Almost all great companies are
founded by at least two people,
and sometimes more.
But nonetheless,
that the founders
have stuck around even when
the adult supervision comes in.
I think that has
been a lesson that
has been learned from watching
these companies where founders
haven't stuck around,
and it's problematic.
I think, too, all of the
things that people associate
with Silicon Valley perks
now, like broad distribution
of stock options
is a great example.
Even a lot of things
like free lunch, sports,
sporting equipment, and
stuff happening on campus,
a lot of that cultural stuff
came directly from this time
period that I'm talking about.
This company ROLM,
where Fawn Alvarez
worked, which is now a parking
lot at the 49ers stadium,
that company was incredible.
They had jogging paths, and
they had a three-month paid
sabbatical after
seven years of work.
And all of these sorts of
benefits that I'm talking about
speak to what I think
companies have really
learned in the Valley,
which is that the people are
the most easily
lost and the most
valuable part of a company.
And that, I think,
again, is something
that's been embedded in the DNA
for a long time at this point.
ALAN MOSS: Yeah.
That's a great point.
All right, up to your questions.
We have a mic on the side.
Please don't be bashful.
LESLIE BERLIN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I really
enjoyed reading the book,
and I think the
title is perfect.
LESLIE BERLIN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And I had
a question related
to the last one
about a common thread
through many of the stories.
It seems to me that one story
that repeated over and over
is a large organization or a
group of people either failing
to see the value in
some of the opportunity
or being unwilling to recognize
it, maybe in Stanford's case.
Warner with Atari, Stanford
with these patents,
HP, like you mentioned before,
with Apple-- this pattern seems
to repeat over and over
again throughout the stories
and creates the opportunity
for the troublemaker.
So in the context of
today, we have a new set
of large, powerful organizations
that clearly learned something.
I'm curious whether they've
managed to sort of subsume
the troublemakers?
Is there something
structurally different now,
or is it inevitable that
today's powerful organizations
and institutions will miss the
next big valuable opportunity,
just like you
described in your book?
LESLIE BERLIN: So will
today's big companies
be able to avoid the fate of--
the classic innovator's dilemma,
as Clay Christensen puts it,
right?
So a lot of people would
say that the big companies
today are trying to
avoid this by acquiring
all the small companies.
Which, there's some real
debate as to whether that's
a threat to Silicon
Valley's future,
if all of the small companies
get eaten up by the big ones.
It's a legitimate
question to ask, actually.
But there's no way that great
companies aren't coming out
of these big companies, and
won't continue to do so.
I think that the other thing
that so much of this innovation
happening in software has
done because it's decreased
the capital
requirements so much,
and because it's made
it possible for people
to work in lots of places that
are not all Silicon Valley,
is the question of where
else are these ideas going
to be coming from?
Because you know so many of
these companies that come out
of bigger companies come because
there are a couple of, usually,
engineers who can't
get something done
at their big company,
and they decide
to go off and do it themselves.
And those people are finding
each other in other ways
now, which I think
is interesting.
I don't think that Silicon
Valley has obsoleted itself
by making location unimportant.
I think that the serendipity
factor of just sort of being
able to walk down the street--
I mean, we met in our
daughters' kindergarten classes
a million years ago--
there's no replacing that.
I don't worry for Silicon
Valley's future or the future
of innovation at all.
I just think that the way that
I described there being multiple
streams that can feed it,
I think those streams now
have their origin points way--
in various places
all over the world.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, mine's
kind of related,
thinking of the small companies
being consumed by larger ones.
Don Norman came and talked
at Google about a year ago,
and afterwards there was
a great discussion around,
because he talked
about places like Xerox
PARC and these wonderful
innovation centers
and even before that or
around that time, Bell Labs.
And he kind of bemoaned
the fact that he
didn't know if that
was the case nowadays,
if you have spaces like that.
And if you do have spaces
like that, a lot of times
they're under the umbrella
of a larger company.
And so thinking back
to passing the batons,
there's been baton
passes from big company,
or from a place like maybe
Apple that's already a bigger
company to another big company.
I'm wondering if Xerox
PARC, do you think,
has passed the baton
to another place that
can provide this kind of
exploratory environment
for that type of
innovation that's maybe--
well, I guess it
wasn't independent,
because it was also
attached to Xerox, but yeah.
LESLIE BERLIN: Right.
Yeah, well, I mean
this is sort of--
Google sponsors a bunch of
moon launch-y project kinds
of things, right?
I think that's something that
we see people being interested
in at the big companies.
I was on a panel
with an early hacker,
and someone asked a
question similar to this.
And so I'll just sort of
parrot back what he said,
because I thought it was
interesting-- not something
I really know about.
He was talking about all the
maker spaces and the hacker
spaces, and the
ability of people
to do real innovation without
needing the underlying
infrastructure of a big
company to sponsor the work.
Now, the question of
what can that impact be--
I don't know.
One of the first articles
I wrote for the New York
Times was about a guy, Johnny
Chung Lee, who had hacked a Wii
and then turned it into a very
cheap whiteboard for schools,
and how the way he got
that invention out there
was through YouTube.
And how this had completely
bypassed the typical research
structure of a
person working alone
or with a small team in
an academic environment
and then waiting forever to get
your paper accepted somewhere
for publication, and
get it peer reviewed,
get it out there where, like,
four people will read it.
But this had created
a completely new way
to disseminate information,
in the same way we've
seen with Twitter and
all of the other things
that have created this mass
explosion of information.
And then he went on to go
to Microsoft Research, which
is interesting.
I think he's moved
on since then.
So I think there are
opportunities out
there for sure.
AUDIENCE: Great, thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I've
heard a lot of people
say that modern devices
seem to be a lot less
tinkerable and
hackerable. [? Usual ?]
computers you're programming
in BASIC yourself.
Now it seems like
the interaction flow,
especially if
[? you're going to just ?] use
certain apps in predefined ways.
So for the future
talent pipeline,
how do we keep raising this
next generation of tinkerers
who are reverse engineering
their electronics and so forth?
LESLIE BERLIN: Yeah.
So I will say this has
been a concern for a while.
The people even coming
straight out of the--
well, honestly,
people were worried
when we moved away from cars.
This is something that I
really remember Bob Noyce had
to talk to his family about.
Because you can see how
to take apart an engine,
but what about with these chips?
You can't do that with chips.
You can't do that
with electronics.
So the bar keeps getting raised.
That said, it's a
legitimate question.
And I think that those
kids are learning
the same kind of creativity
within a differently defined
set of limits.
And I don't know
the answer of, how
do you crack those limits
open further to kind of return
to the level of
something more tangible?
But it is an important question.
Because having the playground so
tightly defined by other people
is troublesome.
I don't know how it's
going to play out.
I think that a lot of
people see real hope
for sort of a freer internet.
I know you were talking
on the device level,
but on the broader level.
In the blockchain,
as some place that
has less control,
less different spaces.
I don't know if we could
come up with something
analogous beyond sort
of typical open source
stuff on a smaller level.
ALAN MOSS: Comes down
to open source versus
walled garden sort of debates.
LESLIE BERLIN: Do you
have any thoughts?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, actually
I'm glad you mentioned
the blockchain, because,
it's kind of clich,
but that was going to be-- if I
were to ask a second question,
it was going to be your
thoughts on cryptocurrencies.
LESLIE BERLIN: Yeah, I'm
passing on my thoughts
on cryptocurrencies.
I don't know enough.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: All right, thanks.
LESLIE BERLIN: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you very much for your
amazing book about the story
of Silicon Valley.
My question is, just like
Fairchild popped and seeded
the semiconductor
evolution, do you
see not a popping, but seeds
from Silicon Valley being
planted in other areas
throughout the world?
And would that perhaps
be an interesting story
for a next book?
LESLIE BERLIN: Yeah.
So absolutely.
I think that the
circulation of people
in and out of Silicon Valley
from other parts of the world
is completely bringing the model
to other parts of the world
and refining the model
here in the Valley.
There's an interesting book,
it came out many years ago,
by a woman named
AnnaLee Saxenian called,
"The New Argonauts"
that talks about exactly
this, the sort of people who
come, the sort of communities
that are made by different
immigrant groups.
And then they go back.
And again, I would really
point to if Silicon Valley,
if the United
States, wants to hold
on to its edge as
an innovator, we
need to be doing what we
can to make sure that people
have an incentive to stay here.
I think another vector,
before I forget,
other than the entrepreneurs
themselves, is, of course,
a lot of the venture companies
have built arms or offices
around the world.
The one approach that
I think is probably not
going to work very
well is sometimes
you see these top-down
government efforts
in other parts of the world to
sort of force a Silicon Valley.
We're going to
build a tech region.
If you build it, they will come.
That doesn't really
seem to work.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: I love the
history of the Valley.
I love the stories.
So thanks for sharing those.
So one thing is as true in
this current environment
of mega companies like Facebook,
and Google, and others,
that it seems to be
that the start-ups are
aspiring more to being a
target, acquisition target,
than really becoming a
strong, independent-- like
entrepreneurialism seems to
be not so much at present.
So any comment on how do
you bring the culture back?
It seems to
[INAUDIBLE] is somewhat
[INAUDIBLE] in this kind
of current environment.
LESLIE BERLIN: Mhm.
So I think I might take a little
bit of issue with that premise.
I actually think there are a
lot of entrepreneurs out there
who are aspiring to build
great, great companies
for the long haul.
I think that those
aspirations can [LAUGHS]
evaporate when someone offers
enormous sums of money.
Something that came through
in this book again and again
and again and again
is how hard it is to start
a company, how hard it
is to get this off the ground,
even with all the support
that you have.
How many people are in
your camp rooting for you?
However great your network
is, it's super hard.
And I don't think
anybody would ever
make it through the sixth
consecutive day of 20
hours of work if they were
like, someday someone else
is going to run this all.
It's just not something
that people aspire to,
I think, as a group.
I think you can get very tired,
and money can look very good.
And it becomes
something you want.
But I think it's pretty
cynical, let's put it that way,
to start sort of
like, my dream is
to build an acquisition target.
You know?
AUDIENCE: I really
liked your analogy
about the seeds that
spread, the pot of seeds
that spread, and in grow the
next generation of companies,
so like the PayPal Mafia--
[LAUGHTER]
--at Xerox PARC, Fairchild.
I was curious, is
there a common strain
in how these groups form?
Do you think they're just
incredible individuals who
sort of find each other?
Or do you think there's a
way of working together,
like a worldview, that's learned
once they sort of come together
under some great leader,
or something like that?
LESLIE BERLIN: Ah,
that's a superb question.
The three examples I cited,
Fairchild, PARC, and PayPal,
what they have in common is that
those people, in every case,
knew each other
before they got there.
So if anyone's read the new
book "Brotopia," which I think
is a very interesting
and good book,
one of the things that
it really points to
is who gets left out when you're
only bringing into your culture
people who you know from
a previous experience.
And there's really smart
reasons to do that.
Namely, you guys are
all thinking similarly.
You get to skip the
acculturation step, because oh,
we all worked together at
Shockley Semiconductor-- let's
go start Fairchild.
Or, we all got contracts from
ARPA under this guy Bob Taylor,
and he likes the
way we think, we
like the way he thinks, so
we're all going to just come
together, start PARC.
Or, we were all at
Stanford together
sort of on the conservative
paper, and such--
except for Reid Hoffman, who
was kind of like their foil.
Now let's all go and
start PayPal together.
So that is something that
they've had in common.
Google is an interesting
counter-example
to that, because
Google, for example,
included women early
on, very early on.
People like Wojcicki and Marissa
Mayer and Sheryl Sandberg.
So that's a story of a different
potential model than the,
we're all in sync.
And it appears to have worked.
ALAN MOSS: One more question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Along the lines of
where you were talking
about how these companies
like Fairchild Semiconductor,
they grow then they pop.
I'm just thinking right now,
the dominant companies that
are in the area, like
Google, Facebook, Apple,
they're just taking--
we're just taking so much real
estate all over the place.
I remember here used to
be [INAUDIBLE] we have.
I was with a company
[INAUDIBLE] previously.
Now Google's taken
all those campuses.
Do you see any dangers
or concerns that,
if Google were to
pop-- fortunately it
won't, hopefully--
all this real estate
that it controls,
all the land, and all
the different buildings,
what would happen to it?
LESLIE BERLIN: Wow.
So now we're getting into--
the beautiful thing
about being a historian
is you never have to
predict the future.
[LAUGHS] I don't know.
I can tell you that one thing
Silicon Valley history teaches
quite well is that great things
happen in economic declines.
So you don't have to
have any customers to buy
your stuff when you're
starting the company.
You're trying to get it going.
So all of a sudden, office
space would be cheaper.
You would have people
who are highly trained
but are not employed.
I think that you might
see another flowering
of innovation.
ALAN MOSS: Scarcity
breeds clarity.
LESLIE BERLIN: Exactly.
ALAN MOSS: Yeah, that's great.
Awesome.
Well, Leslie, thank
you so much for sharing
your incredible insight
and providing perspective
on not only our industry,
but where many of us live.
It's been fabulous to have
you, and we look forward
to having you again
at Talks at Google.
LESLIE BERLIN:
Thank you very much.
It's my pleasure.
[APPLAUSE]